raise your hand you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood you got to have a low
cholesterol diet otherwise you're going
to get heart disease right doctors would
like to blame all cardiovasular disease
on cholesterol we've known for 75 years
in the animal industry that cholesterol
is not a boogeyman there's not a single
disease is caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides you can find
me one I'll give you a million dollars
in small bills in any offshore account
you want there's not a single disease is
caused by elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides elevated blood cholesterol
and triglycerides are really just a
warning signal much like a fever fevers
don't cause infections but when you have
an infection with a bacteria a virus a
fungus maybe a parasite you can get a
fever you can have a broken leg and get
a fever you can have cancer and get a
fever you can have liver disease and get
a fever babies get a fever when they
teeth and so you have to kind of sort it
out when somebody comes into a doctor's
office with a fever you have to say well
okay here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis all the things
that cause fever if they're 80 years old
you can quickly rule out teething
right but the rest of you may have to do
some lab tests for them any rate the
same thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides when you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland you could have diabetes
you could have deficiencies of nasin
chromium vadium the essential fatty
acids you could have liver disease all
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides but they in themselves
don't cause any problems now the eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet that's 98% red meat and
blubber uh they whale meat whale blubber
walrus meat walrus blubber seal meat
seal blubber bare meat bare fat there's
not a single Eskimo above the Arctic
Circle that has a Mr juice man juicer
eats our ganly grown
broccoli their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350 and yet they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us then when they
get the cardiovascular disease they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle they start eating whale blubber
again it goes away well learning all
that I felt very confident in telling my
patients look we're going to do
something different my goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100 I don't want my
patients D at 75.5 I want to give them
another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be 100 and
we're going to do something different if
you want to do everything that all the
other doctors and patients are doing I
want you to go to them because I don't
want you to lower my average right we're
going to do something different it's
just real simple